bonjour clé remis au bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france on commence par par
cette polémique des accusations comme le
secours catholique on parlait de
policiers qu'il a serré des tentes à
calais notamment est ce que pour vous
c'est crédible
il est absolument certain a loupé sur
des démantèlements
après on peut jouer sur les mots 1
pendant longtemps les policiers à les
ramasser et même le matériel vêtements
ils seront accompagnés de société de
ménage est donc ce sont les gens qui
nettoie ma serre ceci dit c'est beaucoup
plus simple à calais c'est assez de
ramasser ce qui finalement à la fin
n'est pas tellement différent quelqu'un
et les 100 ans elles sont en bonne état
on a tous en fait bien chaud
ce drame terrible qui a eu lieu la
semaine dernière avec ces personnes qui
sont mortes voulant traverser la manche
aujourd'hui quelles sont vos missions
très concrètement auprès de ces
personnes migrantes
alors ni notre agent fran ouvrage notre
travail continue l'association salam
c'est essentiellement distribuée
développa et d'en tuer le mans quand on
peut quand on a un peu les moyens en vue
des couvertures des vêtements chauds
c'est d'abord alimentaire et bruno
naufrage bas naufrage beaucoup mais je
vous avouerai que ça fait du bien
d'aller préparer à manger parce que
sinon ces histoires de ce naufrage nous
tourner dans la tête c'est terrible et
le fait d'avoir les mains occupées les
s'occuper d'aller voir des gens qui ont
faim à qui on donne à manger qui font un
sourire ça fait du bien est ce que le
traumatisme vous sentez le traumatisme
est toujours là
oui bien sûr que le traumatisme et là
évidemment un ne disparaît pas en trois
jours ceci dit ils sont dotés des gens
qui de toute façon mal son mal parce que
j'ai vite dans l'amour des bâches
quelques prix n'ont même pas de bâche
donc on ne peut pas dire que ensemble
vraiment une grosse différence
d'ambiance à l'ambiance était
pas évidemment de vouloir recommencer
pour gagner l'angleterre
quand on est complètement acculé canton
mais débouté un lobby d'europe
quand on est du bli nez c'est à dire
qu'on a des empreintes digitales on doit
demander l'asile dans le pays dans
lequel pour la première fois la police a
pris vos empreintes donc on ne peut pas
demander l'asile en france
on est coincé qu'on est en plus à calais
ou à grande synthe dans des conditions
matérielles épouvantable a grandi simple
ils ont été chassés de la commune et ils
censurent je sais pas trop si c'est
mardi que le noble âge mais vraiment
dans une bande mou sans point d'eau
comment voulez vous qu'on renonce à un
projet quand on se dit que ça permettra
de mener une vie normale qui s'applique
malin va le mener une vie normale avoir
un travail un logement gagner leur vie
éventuellement rembourser l'argent
violent passage au pays
ils peuvent pas rester comme ça alors
plus de policiers plus de gendarmes
annoncé à calais la création d'antennes
régionales pour lutter contre les
passeurs aidé à cette problématique
c'est une mesure nécessaire selon vous
alors les passeurs sont des types
épouvantable ne comptez pas sur moi
avant des défunts mais les pacers de son
contrairement à ce qu'a dit monsieur
darmana ne sont pas la cause de la
situation une conséquence les passeurs
c'est une chose impossible à éviter
quand tu as une frontière interdit en 40
y avait une frontière au milieu de la
france les gens qui passaient de la zone
occupée à la zone libre vous avez besoin
de passeurs a tourné dans un pays une
situation de crise on prend pas
l'autoroute on prend pas le train doit
passer par des chemins détournés qu'on
ne connaît pas par des moyens détournés
sur lesquelles on n'a pas prise et c'est
ça que sont les passeurs nous offre les
solutions matérielles à des gens qui ont
besoin de passer qui doivent pas prendre
le délai ils peuvent pas prendre
l'eurostar mais c'est pas les coupables
mais c'est pas l'origine du mal oui donc
finalement doubler les effectifs
policiers pour vous ça n'aura que peu
d'impact sur le nombre de candidats au
passage ça n'aura pas d'impact où les
passeurs parce que c'est comme pour les
trafics de drogue quand ils sont arrêtés
ce immédiatement renoncer ça aura un
impact sur les conditions de passage des
migrants ils ont commencé à passer par
la mer parce que c'est devenu traître
oubliée par les camions et si on
complique trop les passages par la mer
par les bobos dépassera la nage et laura
sont bons plus on complique les passages
et plus les gens risquent là ça il faut
jamais oublier
du coup vous qui êtes sur le terrain
quelles solutions vous souhaitez voir
mises en place aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui a besoin d'un très
bien avec angleterre là il ya des rares
une réunion interne
internationale les anglais en ont été
exclus bon d'accord c'était pas bruce
kisame le fait mais c'est pas parce que
quelque chose quelqu'un fait quelque
chose de pas bien qu'on arrête de lui
parler de concret pour le rencontrer
mais il faut voir avec avec osk ont
modifié il ya des choses à modifier là
ils sont en train de lancer des cépages
espère que global faible lancer des
idées comme refouler les bateaux qui
arrivent le président pauthe anglaise
comme afin de mettre quatre ans prison à
ce qu'ils entrent de manière irrégulière
c'est des choses qui sont inadmissibles
comme qu'on repousse les gens c'est
incroyable ces gens ils risquent leur
vie par un passage allez on va leur
faire risquer leur vie par un passage
retour ceci dit la france doit apprendre
et modeste aussi parce que quand à la
frontière italienne on refoule les gens
alors on met pas leur vie en danger en
exemple passer de l'autre côté de la
ligne n'en n'a quand même pas que ce
droit de les renouveler que les anglais
n'ont le droit de nous battre
ensuite il faut il faut envisager
monsieur darmana la td voltaire vraiment
et pour ça il faut s'asseoir avec les
anglais par les exploits il faut des
moyens légaux de passage jonquet des
gens en france et étudie des anglais il
étudie les demandes d'asile ça s'appelle
le corridor humanitaire
on a son dossier examiné à l'origine et
on passe après avec un papier à visa de
façon légale et ça ça doit être
travaillé ce doit être mis en place la
législation européenne autorise ainsi
dans les dents les textes de la loi
européenne alors évidemment anglet
entité laurent ils obligeaient leurs
hommes de coûts réseau quitté dublin et
ne doivent pas envoyé des secours pour
laurent dans un autre pays d'europe
alors conclu que la ville allait pas y
aller
merci beaucoup ce sera le mot de la fin
merci claire mio de nous avoir répondu
ce matin en direct dans la matinale rt
france